نستعرض ايضا هذا الخبر من روسيا حيث اعلن
جهاز الامن الفيدرالي الروسي اعتقال مراسل
صحيفه وولو جورنال الامريكيه ايفان جيرش
كوفيتش وبحسب بيان للامن الروسي
ان جريشكو يشتبه في قيامه بعمليات تجسس من
بينها جمع معلومات عن المجمع الصناعي
العسكري الروسي لصالح الولايات المتحده
وتم احتجازه وكان اخر مقال نشره يوم امس
في صحيفه وول ستريت بشان تحول الاقتصاد
الروسي الى الانهيار وتقلص الميزانيه
وانخفاض الاستثمارات
كاتيا بشان اعتقال هذا المراسل الصحفي في
الهولوستريت جورنال ماذا لديك من معلومات
حتى الان
بالفعل نايف كانت منذ قليل قد تحدثت وسائل
الاعلام الروسيه عن ان الجيش الامن
الفيدرالي الروسي قام باعتقال الصحفي
التابع الذي يعمل لصالح وول ستريجونال تم
اعتقاله في مدينه
وتم فتح قضيه تحقيق ايضا حول
وجهت اتهامات اليه حول تجسس لصالح
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كان يقوم كما
قال الامن الفيدرالي بانه كان يجمع
معلومات عن احد المؤسسات المجمع الصناعي
العسكري الروسي وهي طبعا تشكل سرا من
اسرار الدوله كما تحدثت لك هذا منذ الصباح
طبعا حتى الان لا يوجد اي تفاصيل جديده هو
من مواليد عام
1991 هو يعمل في مدينه موسكو او في
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو لصالح هذه الصحيفه
ومعتمد طبعا لدى وازاله الخارجيه الروسيه
واجتبها في انه يقوم بجمع هذه المعلومات
التي تشكل تشكل سرا من اسرار الدوله كما
ذكرت لك نايف
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من موسكو مراسله العربيه
كاتيا على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل